would you rather date a girl who laughs  at everything or laughs at nothing uh  laughs at everything uh someone that  laughs at nothing is not living  that's a zombie  and i can't stand being with people like  that and i don't care if you're a guy or  a girl or whatever you are [ __ ] laugh  what about like you're out you're out to  dinner with a bunch of people and like  the one douchebag in the group that you  hate is saying something and she's like  oh yeah yeah yeah yeah  yeah yeah yeah that that's breakup yeah  that's breakup because obviously that's  not funny right you're not laughing in  case you're gonna take the girl never  laughs well in that situation  [ __ ] them both